Joe and surf's has been turning out posh
popcorn in West London for almost 10
years building a business at home and
abroad 15% of their products are sold in
Europe but in less than 90 days
exporting to the continent currently a
seamless process will get considerably
harder if the UK leaves without a deal
we're a small business right we're a
family business we haven't got the huge
budgets of some of these larger
companies who will have people dedicated
to figuring out a way of dealing with No
Deal so we're gonna do a lot less than
some of those bigger companies which
means we're getting to be less prepared
with no preferential treatment after
October the 31st any company that wants
to export to Europe will need to
register with customs for an economic
operator registration and identification
number
Ian for short they've done it here but
they're in a minority so far seventy
thousand businesses have successfully
signed up for an e or e number that
still leaves a hundred and seventy
thousand businesses that's two-thirds of
those the government estimates may need
to register in the event of no deal
those that have registered account for
75% of trade with the EU by volume
companies like this have done what they
can to try and reduce the cost and
inconvenience of No Deal but there is a
limit to what they or anyone else can do
because so much from the basic terms of
trade with Europe to what will actually
happen at the borders is still unknown
it isn't just small companies that
aren't ready Sky News understands that a
major high street food outlet has only
recently begun preparing for customs
changes despite the threat of No Deal in
the spring
experts warn time is short I think
companies are aware of what they have to
do I think there's still a limit on the
number of companies that are actually
doing anything about it unfortunately
bigger companies we work with a lot of
big companies and they're well prepared
but equally you'd be surprised by some
of the companies that approach you late
in the day and say
well now we need to do something and it
surprises us sometimes who they are
really Michael Gove the minister in
charge of No Deal was examining
preparations in Dover with the transport
and Home Secretary's next week the
government is expected to launch a
training program to help businesses cope
with an estimated 150 million extra
customs declarations that will result
from No Deal weather brexit is a recipe
for disaster or a sweet free trade
future some may be watching the No Deal
drama through their fingers poor cow so
sky news